we have tons to get you today we're
going to be talking about President
Trump's new proposal on legal
immigration we were talking about the
media blowback cNN's Jim Acosta makes a
total ass of himself I was on Joe
Rogan's show yesterday just tons to get
to I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
so before I get to any of that plus we
have this amazing graphic that
apparently I have not seen yet but I've
been told by staff is incredible
the The Mortal Kombat version of the
Trump White House like the 1990s video
game so we'll get to that in just second
but before we do any of that I first
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Indo Chino so Indo Chino is the
best way to look good there's nothing
better than a well tailored suit we're
not talking off the wrap we are talking
about made from scratch to fit you
that's what endo Chino does they're
making it easy to get a perfectly
tailored suit at an incredible price my
favorite suit one I own kind of a light
blue suit it's from Mendocino it's
terrific three-piece suit vest I look
just like a million bucks - incredible
and it didn't cost me tons of money you
go over to Indo Chino comm and you can
choose from hundreds of top quality
fabrics personalize your suit just the
way you want it whether it's for work or
a wedding in Ticino has suited up
hundreds of thousands of men they're now
the largest made the Metro menswear
brand in the entire world
you pick your fabric to choose your
customizations you can do all of this
online at ENSO chinos calm submit your
measurement place your order and wait
for it to arrive in just a few weeks
they do a wonderful job with the
tailoring and you can also go into their
shops like they have one in Beverly
Hills on Santa Monica Boulevard went in
there the staff is terrific and friendly
they do a wonderful job of making you a
made-to-order suit this week my
listeners can get any premium Enzo Chino
suit for just three hundred seventy nine
dollars at Indo Chino calm when you
enter promo code
Shapiro's at checkout Enzo chinos Calm
use promo code Shapiro at checkout
that's 50% off the regular price for
made-to-measure premium suit again these
are much nicer suits than anything
you're going to be getting off the rack
anywhere
Enzo Chino comm promo code Shapiro for
any premium suit just 379 bucks plus
free shipping and use that primal code
Shapiro also not just so you get the
discount but they know that we sent you
okay so I really want to see this mortal
combat at the white house because I've
heard so much about this so instead of
us waiting until things I like we're
just going to do it now know where I
like it or not so apparently I had I had
asked if they would do a mortal kombat
mashup of staffing decisions over at the
white house so it is scary motioning
Anthony Kenner Moochie vs. Reince
Priebus followed by General John Kelly
the new chief of staff versus Anthony
Skinner Moochie let's see what you guys
came up with
[Applause]
wait
[Music]
[Applause]
wait did you shoot three spectacular
guys look oh well done by the graphics
team over at the Daily wire for that on
that uplifting note let's jump into
something that is good that President
Trump did so um you know what it's been
do we have a good Trump bad Trump on
hand because there's a lot of good Trump
and when there's and when there's a lot
of good Trump I like to play good Trump
bathrooms do we have it available okay
well we will grab that in just a second
but suffice it to say so the production
team is both on top of it and not on top
of it today but there's a lot of good
Trump today so the good Trump begins
with President Trump introducing what
he's calling the raise act first of all
I'm very irritated with the general the
general notion that every bill has to be
some sort of acronym so you come up with
these insanely long names for a bill
just that it is called the Rays Act as
opposed to just being like the
Immigration Act so it's the Rays act but
in any case what the Rays Act does is
actually really good and talk about the
content here was Trump introducing it
yesterday he's standing next to Senators
Tom cotton of Arkansas and David Perdue
of Louisiana the Rays Act is designed to
limiting legal immigration not illegal
immigration that's what the non-existent
wall will be built for we hope that is
why you have seen an increase in actual
enforcement but crackdowns on legal
immigration and I will explain my view
on when legal immigration should be
increased when it should be decreased in
just a second but here's Trump
introducing this bill yesterday the Rays
Act are a I se the Rays Act will reduce
poverty increase wages and save
taxpayers billions and billions of
dollars it will do this by changing the
way the United States issues green cards
to Nationals from other countries the
Rays Act ends
chain migration and replaces our
low-skill system with a new points-based
system for receiving a green card this
competitive application process will
favor applicants who can speak English
financially support themselves and their
families and demonstrate skills that
will contribute to our economy the Rays
Act prevents new migrants and new
immigrants from collecting welfare and
protects us workers from being displaced
crucially the green card reforms then
the raised act will give American
workers a pay raise
by reducing unskilled immigration this
legislation will not only restore a
competitive edge in the 21st century but
it will restore the sacred bonds of
trust between America and its citizens
ok so overall sledge disposals on in
that he's proposing here are just
they're really good they're really good
ok so what the Rays Act does and a lot
of it is really good is it limits legal
immigration and it does a based on
appoints based systems right now we have
a Visa Lottery which is just idiotic why
should it be a lottery to get into the
country we are the greatest country on
the face of the planet in human history
we should be able to choose who comes in
and who does not we should only bring in
people who are beneficial to the country
at large people who can help the economy
people who are going to assimilate
people who are going to integrate people
who are going to better the stock of the
United States and I mean racial stop but
I mean the the intellectual and moral
and and social stock of the United
States you know all of these things that
this is not a very difficult call right
I mean if you were to start a community
you'd want to be pretty selective about
who's allowed to answer the community if
you go to a church or a synagogue you
want to be selective about who's allowed
in your community because you don't want
it being overrun with people who don't
agree all right this is why we have
social clubs because the United States
is a country that is found in on an idea
if you bring in hundreds of millions of
people who don't believe that idea you
got a problem and this has been the
problem with the way that America has
approached emigration since the 1960s so
until the 1960s the vast bulk of the
mcgrann is coming to the United States
we're coming from Western Europe and
some from Eastern Europe and the reason
that that was better than what came
afterward is because one of the criteria
to get in is
number one you weren't going to take
welfare and number two you spoke English
or you are willing to integrate you're
willing to assimilate quickly into an
english-speaking language and in 1967
they decided no longer what they
privilege people who had education who
had degrees who had economic backgrounds
who spoke English who had a history in
Western civilization now we were just
going to take in basically anyone who
applied first-come first-serve what that
did is it change the kinds of people who
are coming over into the United States
not because they're bad people but
because when you change the country's
from what you draw you to change the
cultures from which you draw when you
change the system of governance in the
United States toward welfare based
system you're going to change the kinds
of people who apply for entry I mean if
you if you have a store that's giving
away free product you're going to get a
different clientele than if you have
Burberry's where everything cost a
billion dollars I did is why you have a
different crowd goes to Disneyland and
goes to the Magic Mountain there's Neil
and the prices are much higher very very
different crowd because the Disneyland
that goes to Magic Mountain so none of
this is is really or should be
controversial Trump points out that more
than 50% of all immigrant households
received welfare benefits compared to
only 30% of native households in the
United States who received welfare
benefits which is obviously true he's
also pointed out crime that is connected
with immigration both legal and illegal
people point out that there is not a
tremendous crime wave coming from
immigrants but the question is not
whether there's a wave like above and
beyond what happens in America the
question is whether the people who are
being brought in are more likely to
behave like people at the lower end of
the socio-economic status in the United
States in terms of crime or whether
there's a lot more likely to behave like
people at the higher end of the
socioeconomic status in the United
States with regard to crime my
father-in-law came to the United States
as an engineer from Israel right he
already spoke English he came here was
he likely to commit a crime or was he
more likely to commit a crime if he was
a person who was coming in from El
Salvador with no marketable skills and
was coming in in poverty you know and
trying to provide for his family like
which which one is more likely to
integrate which one is more likely to
provide benefit to the United States
economy so all of this is is good stuff
the other stuff that this does it
rewards education English language
ability high paying job offers past
achievements and entrepreneurial
initiative great it would reduce
immigration among low skilled and
unskilled labor the idea here is twofold
one of these ideas is good and one of
these idea
is bad so the good idea about decreasing
immigration among low skilled and
unskilled labor is that you're bringing
in a group of people who are more likely
to end up on welfare so if you have a
lot of people who are likely to end up
on welfare then it is not worthwhile to
have them come into the United States
the part of this that is that is stupid
is the suggestion that you're
undercutting the labor market by
bringing in immigrants that you're the
wages go down and jobs are lost
okay so wages probably will go down when
you have more supply of labor obviously
the wages go down right I mean demand is
now exceeded by supplied the wages go
down but here's the problem
there are two arguments you can't make
them both simultaneously but Trump does
argument number one China and Mexico are
taking all the jobs argument number two
we have to increase the wages you can't
really say both those things right if
you believe that American companies are
offshoring and outsourcing because wages
in the United States are too high you
can't deliberately drive up the wages in
the United States and then be surprised
when companies outsource the argument
for limiting immigration in order to
drive up wages by limiting the labor
supply is exactly the same as the
argument for minimum wage which I assume
Trump proposes right the fact is minimum
wage artificially drives up the price
you have to pay for labor
this forces businesses to raise their
prices this forces them to be
non-competitive and that forces them to
outsource it forces them to go to other
countries for labor or to fire people
okay the same thing is true if you
artificially drive up the price of labor
by keeping prospective workers from
coming into the United States you're not
going to boost the economy by preventing
workers from coming into the United
States there are only two reasons to
limit immigration into the United States
I'm very libertarian when it comes to
this the only two reasons okay one is
safety and the other is culture and
that's it okay safety well safety
culture welfare really those three okay
so if they're on welfare no if they are
not going to assimilate to the culture
of the United States no and if they are
a threat to safety no otherwise I have
no problem with anybody coming in who
wants to work hard not be on welfare and
compete for jobs and and that's my
really only problem with the way that
Trump is expressing this it's sort of
pandering to an economic falsehood but
the contents of the bill itself is just
fine the content of the bill I'm totally
fine with and I want to explain a little
more about what's in the bill and then I
want to show you an exchange that really
was was making the rounds yesterday as
well should because it demonstrates why
people like me people like you probably
dislike the media so
but before I get to that I first want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
upside comm so I've been telling you for
a while that if you travel for business
you need to stop wasting time pricing
your flights in hotels at the same old
sites you used to go to the only site
you now need is up side that comments
when we hear yous at the Daily wire it
is quick and easy for up side comm to
show you the exact flight you're looking
for and the big-name hotels you want to
stay at you can either buy them
separately or bundle them when you
bundle them you save a lot of money and
when you save a lot of money you also
get a big gift card from Amazon com
every time you buy a business travel
package using up side so you buy a
bundled package and not only are you
getting a more inexpensive package which
accrues the benefit your company you
personally get the Amazon gift card
which is awesome when you go over to
upside down plus they're much more user
friendly than all these other websites
they have expert navigator is always
available 24/7 so the customer service
is great which is what you need when
you're traveling man I can't tell you
how many times have been trying to book
a flight and you really need somebody on
the other end of the phone to help you
through this especially when you're
talking short notice
they have concierge level of service and
it is second to none you get the VIP
treatment while paying low prices and
getting that Amazon gift card every time
you book a package right now when you
use promo code Ben you're guaranteed to
get at least a $100 Amazon gift card on
your package perk is purchased again
that is code Ben when you go to up side
comm you get that $100 gift card for
free up side comm minimum purchase
required seaside for complete details
again go to up side calm and use that
promo code Ben promo code Ben will also
let them know that we sent you okay so
the bill itself would limit refugee
status to 50,000 people a year they
would kill that diversity visa lottery
program which as I said is stupid you
shouldn't have a lottery forever so
that's dumb it would prioritize
immediate family members of people who
emigrate so my father-in-law comes in
now he can bring his wife and children
but it doesn't allow him to bring in his
entire extended family from Morocco
right that's just not a thing this is
what Trump was talking about when he
talks about chain migration this idea
that one person sets roots and then now
you get a thousand people who are the
extended relatives coming in because
that one person settle down we should be
able to pick and choose who we bring
into the country it seems fair that we
would bring an immediate family members
so people who are a benefit to the
country can have their immediate family
around them but I'm not sure why cousin
babo should be allowed into the country
just because I was allowed into the
country and I'm
benefit to the United States so all of
this is really good stuff I mean like
like top-notch stuff there the biggest
problem is that this is not going to
pass right so Dianne Feinstein Democrat
from California she was saying this is
not going to pass in all likelihood it
can be very difficult to get people like
John McCain on board and here is Dianne
Feinstein you know suggesting as much so
it's it's a program that I hope candidly
won't see the light of day I don't know
whether it will or not but I think in
the Judiciary Committee it's not going
to be very welcomed does this the White
House said Stephen Miller and the
president they kept referring to the
what they call the fact that this new
policy this new immigration policy would
help African Americans and Hispanic
workers who are here in the United
States you accept that well I can't I
don't see how candidly I don't see how
when you cut back on all of these
categories which make America help
America to be what the Statue of Liberty
says and we do it within reason and
there have been cutbacks and there are
long lines okay so and it is you just
went into commerce because why Trump is
really doing and not if you think that
this is going to pass but because it's a
good political move exactly the stuff
he's talking about with immigration that
I dislike is the stuff that a lot of
voters like they want to be told that
the reason they're losing their jobs is
because of these people coming across
the border legally on low wage visas who
are taking their jobs and the truth is
that there is some of that going on like
to pretend that in the short term there
is not a job substitution that happens
when low wage immigrants come into the
United States would be foolish of course
there's a substitution that happens what
I'm saying is in the medium to long term
you end up with a net loss of jobs as
businesses close their doors in the same
way that a union will break a company
and the company will end up moving out
of state or out of country limiting the
labor supply inevitably means the higher
cost to the company so in the mid to
long term it's bad economics but for
those people who are living in Ohio or
Michigan and they're afraid that
bringing in low-wage labor is going to
undercut them of course that's what
they're pandering to it's a political
move for Trump to talk about that stuff
I'm in favor of the bill because we
ought to be picking and choosing the
people who come into the
and making sure that they actually are
not on welfare are not safety threats
and are going to assimilate to the u.s.
culture now the media don't know the
first thing about immigration the
history of immigration in the United
States is filled with ebbs and flows
there are times when there were tons of
immigrants coming to the United States
in 1907 when my great-great grandfather
got to the United States Harry Shapiro
and him in 1907 they're 1:1 over a
million immigrants that came into the
United States that year mostly from
Western and Eastern Europe that's not
rare in the in US history but then there
was a crack down in the 1920s an
immigration plummeted so we've had times
when there's lots of immigration times
and there's not as much immigration and
this sort of ebb and flow in terms of
immigration is perfectly natural there's
nothing quote-unquote nativists about it
depending on the motives you know and
sometimes there is nativist sometimes
they're trying to ban the Chinese or ban
the Jews or ban the Irish or ban the
Germans but in this particular case
that's not what's going on here this is
a case that you have to have people who
are willing to assimilate and you have
to have people who are not safety
threatened people who are not going to
be on welfare all of which seems
perfectly decent to me now what happened
the media because they are so eager to
call President Trump a racist sexist pig
and homophobe and all the rest they
immediately decide without any evidence
that this bill is based on racism right
this is their routine so Stephen Miller
a guy I know and who was definitely an
expert on immigration I mean as I've
said before I remember in it must been
2013 there was an event or two would've
been 2014 actually 2014-15 there's an
event at which I did it was like a
late-night dinner slash drinking session
with Stephen Miller and Coulter's Jeff
Sessions and me and Stephen knows what
he's talking about when it comes to
immigration this is his specialty this
is where he's no his manner is very
aggressive and that's abrasive to some
people but the person who gets hammered
here is not Stephen Miller it's Jim
Acosta Jim Acosta is the reporter from
CNN he doesn't know anything about
immigration like nothing about
immigration you're going to see that on
full display in this particular clip
what you're proposing where the
president is proposing here does not
sound like it's in keeping with American
tradition when it comes to immigration
the statute Liberty says give me your
tired
poor your huddled masses yearning to
breathe free doesn't say anything about
speaking English or being able to
computer be a computer programmer aren't
you trying to change what it means to be
an immigrant coming into this country if
you're telling them you have to speak
English to learn how to speak English
when they okay so there's nothing wrong
with telling people they need to learn
how to speak English I love this idea
from the left then from the media that
what it says in Emeril Lazarus's poem on
the Statue of Liberty is somehow US law
so when it says it says give us your
tired your your weary or huddled masses
yearning to be free
well the key phrase in that actually
what everyone seems to be ignoring is
yearning to be free okay doesn't say
yearning for free stuff
it means yearning to be free so the
English language requirement is only a
requirement now because we've had two
generations of immigrants who have not
bothered to learn English in many cases
their kids learn English but they
themselves have not like when my
great-great-grandfather came to the
United States he spoke Yiddish his kids
did not speak in US it was actually
forbidden in the household for them to
speak Yiddish because they wanted their
kids to learn English and integrate into
American society that's not the way that
it works anymore now in me here in
California we have the English as second
language right you have folk classes
taught in Spanish in public schools you
know that is not the way that we were
told immigration was supposed to work so
when you have Jim Acosta doing me you
know huddled masses yearning to be free
the immediate and obvious point is okay
Jim there have to be some restrictions
on immigration what would you propose
those be should we just welcome 7
billion people into the United States
everyone come in because clearly you
think that's what I'm a Lazarus this
poem means if you want to come here you
should be able to come here well that
would immediately destroy the United
States as it stands and that's where
Stephen Miller goes with us here well
first of all right now it's a
requirement that it be naturalized yet
dissipate English so the notion that
speaking English going to be a part of
immigration systems would be actually a
very a historical secondly I don't want
to get off into a whole thing about
history here but the Statue of Liberty
is a symbol of Liberty enlightening the
world is a symbol of American liberty
lighting the world the poem that you're
referring to was added later it's not
actually part of the original Statue of
Liberty but more fundamentally the
history they said more fundamentally
saying history not represent I'm saying
that benefactors
Oshin I'm saying the notion that the
kissing the notion I'm sorry no there's
why you're not sound gay let me ask you
about that sounds like some national
park revisionist know what I'm asking
you is that your memory chip has oh yeah
let me ask you about hope to the world
Jim for people to say do you believe to
this country in Punjab always will this
be human copula subjugated prosper Singh
he's being such a contentious douchebag
Jim Acosta right here I mean this is
like even if you think that Jim Acosta
is correct on this Jim Acosta just
badgering cismo not even letting him get
an answer in his a press conference
right you ask a question you get an
answer maybe you get a follow-up but the
idea that you just get to grandstand
there's one of the reasons why the White
House demanding a lot of flack for the
Senate saying we don't want on camera
press conferences why because it's
complete waste of time because people
like Jim Acosta are trying to edge in
and seal all the air time so maybe Jim
Acosta can one day get a show on CNN I
mean that's really what this is you know
right after this happened he started
tweeting out lines from Emma Lazarus his
poem okay this is the same guy who said
we are not fake news mr. president
didn't news to be tweeting outlines from
from Emma Lazarus's poem
it hasn't been news for nigh on a
hundred years more than a hundred years
that hasn't been news been a while since
that was actually plastered on the
Statue of Liberty you know this is
advocacy it's issue advocacy which is
fine I advocate pressures all the time
but for Jim Acosta and CNN to pretend
this is objective journalism is just a
joke it continues along these lines
skill there I'm Jim be Jim Jim I
appreciate your speech Jim I appreciate
so let's let's talk about this the
modest the Jim let's talk about this in
1970 when we let in 300,000 people a
year is that violating or not violating
the Statue of Liberty law of the land in
nineteen in the 1990s when it was half a
million a year was that violating or not
violating the Statue of Liberty law of
the land what it was seven hundred
thousand year astronauts tell me what
years and tell me what years tell me
what years me tell me what years meet
Jim Acosta definition of the Statue of
Liberty home law of the land so you're
saying a million a year is the Statute
of Liberty number 900,000 violates at
800,000 violates that you're sort of
bringing ms1 for English philosophy here
generation and that's number four
Jim what the
nine states has been about your also
your statements also shocking the
historical in another respect to which
is if you look at the history of
immigration it's actually ebbed and
flowed we've had periods of very large
waves followed by periods of less
immigration and more immigration right
and during the event here immigration
right now yeah it wants to bill is
actually you want to is every about a
sweeping James earlier Jim you don't
actually think that a wall affects
green-card policy you couldn't possibly
believe that do you actually the notion
that you actually think immigration is
it a historic law if for born population
the United States today
Jim Jim talking about how border
crossing do you really well I want to be
serious him do you really at CNN not
into the difference between green card
policy and illegal immigration sir I
mean you really don't know that you came
to this country 1962 right before the
Cuban Missile Crisis in obtained a green
card yes people who have okay so again
eventually people who race back under
not through a factual and Jim as a
factual question weighs do a obtain a
green card at some point they do it
through a lot of hard work and yes they
may learn English as a second language
later on in life so but but this whole
notion of well they could learn you know
they have to learn English before they
get to the United States are we just
going to bring in people from Great
Britain in Australia so actually I only
say I am shocked at your statement that
you think that only people from Great
Britain and Australia would know English
it's actually it reveals your
cosmopolitan bias to a shocking degree
that in your mind no this is an amazing
this is an amazing moment this is an
amazing moment that you think only
people from Great Britain or Australia
would speak English it's so insulting to
millions of hard-working immigrants who
do speak English from all over the world
Tim have you honestly Jim have you
honestly never met a immigrant from
another country okay Andy Miller I want
to be right on this okay what he is
saying here is exactly right there are
more english-speaking people in China
then all of the UK and the United States
put together okay there are more
english-speaking people in India than
there are in the United Kingdom in
Australia why because there are lots of
people in India right there are lots of
people in China there
people to enjoy 'no and probably a third
of them speak English right 40% of them
probably speak some form of English if
you go to Israel everybody speaks
English right Hebrews the first language
everybody speaks English in Israel you
go to Italy everybody speaks English you
go to France everybody speaks English
the idea that only the UK and Australia
they speak English I mean they teach
English everywhere because English is
the universal language of Commerce right
now and it has been for the last 400
years this idea of it but you know this
is somehow racism and discriminatory
again it doesn't mean that you can't get
in if you don't speak English it means
you get extra points because it's easier
to integrate you into society where you
speak to calm and tone okay but Jim
Acosta it's just demonstrative of what
the media is even though it did a very
good job with this he's getting raked
over the coals by the me by a lot of the
media's oh he's too abrasive he's too
abrasive way to expect them to do Jim
Acosta being a jerk
he's being a jerk now I want to get to
more of this and I want to get to how
the media painted this afterward but for
that are going to have to go over to
Daley wired.com and become a subscriber
for $9.99 a month you too can have a
subscription to the daily wire the most
magical of all websites and podcasts
$9.99 a month you get this show it is a
video show you get it live you get to be
part of the mailbag which we'll be doing
tomorrow on the show you will get Andrew
Clavin show live and you'll get the
mailbag for that as well
you get Michael Moses brand-new show
wait for whatever that's worth I mean
just a throwaway but it's supposed to be
pretty great so check that out you can
get that at $9.99 a month or if you want
the annual subscription than you my
friend then you will be in the greatest
of luck because you will receive in the
mail delivered to you this magical
incredible incomparable leftist here's
hot or cold tumblr it's the greatest
thing you've ever seen it's not
available anywhere else it is available
only from The Daily wire that $99 ear
gets do all the things I just mentioned
the website ad free plus this tumbler
that you will treasure forever and give
to your daughter as a wedding gift on
this her wedding day you will you will
love it you'll treasure it you'll you'll
keep it forever
and you get that with the annual
subscription or if you just want to
listen later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and give us a listen and the
subscription and a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so as you see Stephen Miller absolutely
hammers cNN's Jim Acosta and what does
the copses response to this I mean this
is full-on delusional crap right because
Jim Acosta then goes on CNN and he says
hey man Miller couldn't handle me I was
too much for him
it was odd to see the White House wolf
in the form of Stephen Miller one of the
top policy advisors sort of sound like a
Statue of Liberty originalist as if
there's some difference between what the
Statute of Liberty looked like when it
was first brought over here in the
United States and and what and what it
looks like now with a poem attached to
it I just thought that was an odd moment
it was just a poor argument and whenever
they're bashing the media wolf my sense
always is is that they're just losing
the argument I think you saw that today
which is just a joke I mean there's no
idea watch that exchange and what you
come up with is the Jim Acosta wins this
exchange
he looks ignorant he looks stupid he
looks foolish he actually said though
live on CNN that this was it was obvious
that he couldn't take that kind of heat
even though it couldn't take that kind
of heat he said I think what you saw
unfold in the briefing room is that
Miller just couldn't take that kind of
heat and exploded right before our eyes
um no no that's no one who watched that
thought that that's what where that was
coming from no and you know a constant
intent that Stephen Miller when he says
you have a cosmopolitan biases it's not
often you're accused of a cosmopolitan
bias from someone who went to Duke
University wearing cufflinks in the
White House briefing room not a
completely unfair critique of Stephen
Miller except for the fact that it is a
leftist and left-wing coastal bias like
to pretend that Stephen Miller doesn't
represent the thoughts and feelings of
people in the middle of the country more
than Jim Acosta is just silly but that's
not really what this was about it was
about virtually signalling and Jim
Acosta says that this was a dog whistle
as just a giant dog whistle he says that
quote when you hear about the president
make some of the comments he makes about
immigrants when you see Stephen Miller
our policy talking about this it's a
wink right here's what he had to say
talking about deportation forces and
when you see Stephen Miller a policy
adviser with the president talking about
an English language preference for
people coming into this country it is a
wink it is a dog whistle too
parts of this country that they are
going to be looking at the racial and
ethnic flow of immigrants coming into
this country what absolute horse-pucky
again it's not about the ethnic and
racial flow is about the cultural flow
it's about the income flows but the
education flow but this is what the left
never understood when they made the
immigration case for the last 20 years
they kept saying things like well you
let anybody in and it's not a problem at
all people the middle the country going
wait a second if you like Victor Davis
Hanson lives up in Northern California
central California saying my entire town
has been transformed by people who don't
speak English you don't abide by basic
Western standards of civilization you
know there are a lot of people who
suffer and there is a cosmopolitan
biases I know I live in LA I've lived my
entire life in LA in LA here here's the
truth about how people like like Jim
Acosta and and members of the media
think about this kind of stuff the way
they think about this kind of stuff they
live in very nice houses they went to
top universities and the only time they
see immigrants legal or illegal is
usually when they are working with them
at the top-notch as a business right
they're working with them as like an IT
person or the person comes in and now
they're a nurse right or there or
illegally there's other people who mow
their lawn right the nannies it takes
care of their kids those are the only
people they see they don't ever see the
people who aren't working because the
people who aren't working are down at
the home depot waiting for somebody to
pick them up or alternatively they're in
East LA working with some sort of heroin
cartel right I mean like that the fact
is that most of the people who are
coming in are not participating in
drug-related activity of course but to
pretend that that doesn't exist is just
silly it's just foolish to pretend the
criminal element doesn't exist is
foolish to pretend poverty doesn't exist
as foolish drive over to East LA look
around and tell me that the poverty that
is endemic in that community has nothing
to do with the immigrants who are being
brought in that it's just the American
system that causes that poverty know if
you come in and you bring a bunch of
people who have no skill set then this
is what you are going to get okay that
it's not their fault it's not your fault
that's just the way it is
okay people with no skill set are not
the top choices for the United States to
bring it and that has nothing to do with
race there are a lot of people there
countries in the world where where if
you bring white people in from us I mean
like people don't like to talk about the
fact that you know there are a lot of
Russian immigrants to this country well
presumably this new bill would harm
Russian immigrants to this country if
they can't speak English properly and
have no skill set
people are white so it's not about
ethnicity not about place of birth it's
about culture it's about skillset again
that the left refuses to acknowledge any
of this and so instead they castigate
everyone who agrees with Trump that
maybe we ought to be worried about the
shifting culture of the country based on
bringing in legal immigrants who then
stay illegally by the way we go into
illegal immigration are connected
they're a bunch of people who have
overstayed their their visas for example
that's like half the illegal
immigrations people who came into the
country legally and then overstayed
their visas but Acosta says no this is
this isn't about actually attempting to
protect culture and safety and economic
growth know what this is really about is
the unhealthy fixation on Mexicans the
whole notion that people want to come to
the United States immigrate to the
United States should know English before
they arrive why is that so central to
this new strategy that the president is
putting forward well well if I think at
times this White House has an unhealthy
fixation on what I call the 3ms the
Mexicans the Muslims and the media that
their policies tend to be crafted around
bashing one of those three groups and we
just see it time and again and today on
immigration with the white houses is
essentially saying in a wink and a dog
whistle to some of these battleground
states that they won is that immigrants
coming in from Latin America are taking
your jobs wolf immigration is not the
reason why the factory closed in
Pittsburgh or the coal mine was shut
down in West Virginia the people who are
struggling in those states they need
policies that will help get them out of
this this message they're generous to
saying all this of course used for
policies that redistribute wealth in the
United States in order to help those
people so his idea is that you have to
bring in everybody from Latin America
who has a low skill set and creates wage
competition and then you have to pay
welfare to all the people who are thrown
out of work like that's his idea because
Jim Acosta is on the Left there's all
grandstanding when he says Muslims
Mexicans the media wasn't I'm not in
favor of people attacking Mexicans
during the election cycle and President
Trump went after Judge Carrie Ellen
suggested that because his parents were
Mexican and couldn't be fair in his
trial and said that's disgusting when it
came to his Muslim man I said I don't
think that a full Muslim ban is good
policy but when it comes to the media
there's a reason he's bashing the media
and it's because of
you see on your television screen right
now it's because of Jim Acosta that's
why he's gnashing it's not just costume
by the way Glen thrush over the
Washington Post he and Miller go at it
and here's what that looked like in the
briefing room yesterday as engineering
men right no reason study said that as
much as 300 billion dollars a year may
be lost as a result of our current
immigration system in terms of books
drawing more public benefits and they're
paying in but as also use common sense
here folks at the end of the day why do
special interests want to bring in more
low-skilled workers and why historically
Congress masters well I think it's very
clear done that you know common sense
but if I could just answer and I guess
answer your question I named I named I
named the studies Lennox guns but then I
named the studies I named the studies
for statistic comes out how many the
they will make a carve-out in the bill
that says the New York Times can hire
all the low-skilled less pay workers
they want from other countries and see
how you feel then about low-wage
substitution this is a reality that's
happening in our country maybe it's time
we had compassion Glenn for American
workers President Trump has met with
American workers who've been replaced by
foreign workers and asked them ask them
how this is affected their life again
this is a strong political case again I
don't need a strong factual case in the
long run this is going to help the
economy in any real way but the
political case that he's making against
thrush is out it's an obvious one and
it's not nativism as much as it is you
know the idea that if you don't want
people coming in who are going to
threaten the wage base then you can't
have people coming in who are
low-skilled ok that's an argument with
which I disagree economically but it's
at least a fair argument suggests that
it's based on racism is just nonsense
especially because as miller says a lot
of the low-wage skill in the united
states are people who are black or
hispanic so it but that didn't stop the
rush from ripping miller and then
suggesting that this was you know it's
just terrible just terrible Miller got
mad I think Steven Miller got airtime
and I think he enjoyed it immensely he
was not getting off that stage Sarah
Huckabee Sanders was standing around
long enough to have been charged rent
standing next to him
I'm just going to get out of her and
like hook him after a while I mean he
was like that guy who just kept going
and going and wasn't going well but he
kept going anyway
oh you mean it was scary Meucci esque
right anyway they were actually you're
right is your objective media gang this
is your objective media going out it's
not even people like Anna Navarro a
former Republican strategist okay this
is people like Glen thrush objective
media Jim Acosta objective me to look
objective to you another element of the
objective media today the Washington
Post revealed week's transcripts from
January 27th phone calls made by then
brand new president Donald Trump his
counterparts in Mexico and Australia
it's dangerous stuff okay
they got to crack down on these White
House leaks the content of the calls is
not edifying you know for people who
either support Trump or or oppose Trump
means doesn't show a guy who has
tremendous command of the issues but it
is a serious security issue and you do
have to wonder whether it is worthwhile
for the Washington Post to be printing
full-scale transcripts of national
security related calls to Australia and
New Mexico I mean this is just the media
is out to get Trump there's no question
about it now I've been very critical of
Trump I said that I think Trump needs to
do a better job but when you watch
things like what happened in the White
House briefing room yesterday it is
impossible not to come to the conclusion
that the media have an agenda and they
are going to force that agenda through
and that agenda has nothing to do with
policy and everything to do with
character assault suggesting that
everyone who agrees with some sort of
crackdown on immigration or a change in
the way we do immigration to bring in
people who are more likely to assimilate
and as the economy rather than
subtracting that those people who want
to crack down on that stuff those people
are the bad guys they're evil they're
nasty they're racist it's just that it
should be unacceptable for for the media
to do that but that's their entire game
at this point and that's why Trump
continues to hold his base okay
so time for some things I like some
things I hate and then we'll get to the
big idea so things I like we've been
paying late homage to Anthony scare
Moochie and doing characters who are
like Anthony Skinner Malucci in movies
and he is a stock character from the
films and so this one today's comes from
boiler room
boiler room is a really underrated film
well with Giovanni Ribisi and Ben
Affleck Ben Affleck sort of plays the
the Alec Baldwin Glenn
glen ross part but this is all about
basically a scam firm kind of a wolf of
Wall Street firm as basically a pyramid
scheme they just call people up they
seldom leads on stocks and then when the
stocks collapse then they're not around
to pick up on it they get a commission
based on the amount they sell that has
nothing do with whether the stock goes
up or down and they're paid by companies
to basically sell all the stock these
penny stocks that are not heavily
regulated and then if they collapse no
big deal here's the scene where Ben
Affleck makes the pitch to all of the
prospective Series seven stockbrokers as
to why they should work for his firm
sorry man just messy I'm so salsa
get out of here what don't talk to me
don't look at me just pick it up out of
that Italian leather chair and get in
this room right now come on let's go
schleprock out we expect everyone here
to treat their co-workers with a certain
level of respect okay before we get
started I have one question is anyone
here passed the series 7 exam
obviously area 7 license it's good for
you you can get out too what
why we don't hire brokers here we train
new ones that said Skippy back let's go
okay here's the deal I'm not here to
waste your time okay I certainly hope
you're not here to waste mine so I'm
going to keep this short
become an employee of this firm you will
make your first million within three
years okay I'm going to repeat that you
will make a million dollars within three
years of your first day of employment
and JT Marlin there is no question as to
whether or not you'll become a
millionaire working here the only
question is how many times over okay so
and then that is the scare moocher
routine he eventually goes on in this
little speech talk about how he has the
nicest car and beautiful women and all
this kind of stuff the sort of attitude
people who find this sort of thing
attractive found that attractive the
movies really good actually and and has
some pretty good performances by a bunch
of actors who have had really a lot of
bit roles Affleck is is pretty good in
this role whatever Affleck plays a jerk
he's good whenever Affleck plays
somebody who's supposed to be nice he's
terrible so so the movie is boiler woman
and worth watching other things I like I
talked a lot about Venezuela and Google
Chavez yesterday the best book on this
that I know of is a book by Rory Carol
called commandante which is a biography
of Google Chavez and it is it is quite
good it really explains where he came
from why he was who he was and why
demagoguery works so pick it up worth
reading okay time for a thing I hate so
let's do a thing I hate okay so the
thing I hate today is Al Gore who has
made literally a billion dollars off of
global warming he was on national TV on
CNN and he's talking to a priest and he
explains that global warming is a moral
and spiritual issue
the habits of overconsumption and
looking for happiness in just more
things that definitely is a part of the
issue for sure and now I was taught in
in my church that the purpose of life is
to glorify God and if we are heaping
contempt on God's creation then we're
not living up to the duty that God is
calling us to and so this the way we
live our lives is definitely connected
to this it is it's not politically
double-entry okay
yelling he's selling spiritual solace in
global warming
okay this idea that that this can teach
you not to be so materialistic like if
you were just a little bit less
materialistic then maybe you'd worry
more about global warming
what utter stupidity maybe the reason I
don't worry so much about global warming
is because at best the IPCC says that
we're going to have a seven degree
increase Fahrenheit this is like this is
there outside estimate seven degree
fahrenheit increase over the next
hundred years average across the planet
they also say that there's really no way
to stop a pretty significant temperature
increase from happening anyway even
according to their best estimates and I
have more faith in the human capacity to
adjust to climate change than I do to
the idea that we're all going to
suddenly become communistic
poverty-ridden Saints who share our
property in common
I mean Al Gore has made 200 million
dollars off the scam two hundred million
dollars so before he starts talking to
us about what's really good in life is
having no money dude give up your
private jet and then we can start
talking about it okay so we don't have
time unfortunately this is a big idea
this week because we ran out of time
that is my fault I arrived late to the
studio but we will do it next week
because I think that the Jerusalem
versus the Athens issue is one that has
a lot of ramifications for our politics
but you'll have to wait until next
week's big idea in order for us to do
that Mabel do it early next week instead
but we will see you tomorrow we have the
mailbag we'll bring you all the latest
updates I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]